hi everyone we'll be starting today's
session in five more minutes
thank you for joining
and
meanwhile we begin with the session it
would be great if we could hear it from
you
so hi
sneha can you please introduce
yes sorry for the background noise yeah
so hi sneha can you please introduce
yourself
hello hello everyone
i am
kolkata
now pursuing my vtec in biotechnology
from university of engineering and
management kolkata
so
i'm
i'm very excited to do this internship
thank you
and sneha can i know what motivated you
to join the program
motivated like i
want to do research work in my future
on the infectious disease or cancer
research
so that is the that is my motivation
all right that's great thank you
and hi eta can we uh hear it from you
can you please also introduce yourself
are you saying
i want to learn more about the new
technology as you know i have more than
20 years of experience in indian
medicine grant and their potentials in
that i have worked on more than
350 indian medicinal plant and some of
the arid zone plant i was also back with
dst dad woman scientist a dst dad
indo-german collaboration i have uh so i
have worked a lot many things but you
know as technologies are advancing so
uh you so rapid so i want to know what
kind of things i can learn and can get
the gain and can correlate this with my
practical studies right
that belief i can uh tell you all right
thank you so much
ah that's very interesting actually and
thank you for introducing yourself and
telling us about your feet it's pretty
interesting and yes we are definitely
sure that uh with the resources here
you'll be able to
uh also get the advanced skill set
yes thank you
now i would like to
ask anag if you can please introduce
yourself and
yeah over to you
hi uh i'm anatha and i'm studying
biomedical sciences at nmims mumbai
so i am interested in this program
because in the past year i actually did
a bioinformatics related
research project
and i'm more interested in infectious
diseases because viruses are so elegant
in their design and they can be used for
treating diseases but also we need to
understand how to prevent viral diseases
and so i think this program will help me
understand uh
this better and it will help me in my
future because i hope to study
infectious diseases in detail
all right that's interesting anaga
and uh hi katie how are you katie would
you like to please introduce yourself
hi good morning
can you repeat your morning
let me set up my audio
yeah we can hear you
what was your question
can you please introduce yourself like
tell us about your educational
background or research background and
also what are your research interests
and uh
yeah yeah hi my name's katie um i went
to the university of south carolina and
i got a bachelor's in biomedical
engineering
um
and of course i graduated around cobid
so
that led me down
pairing with the company to
become a full stack software developer
so i've kind of for the past year or so
been
doing that and now i'm taking this
course to kind of get back into
you know the medical field so
this is my first step back
thank you all for having me
all right
all the best for our first step and we
are pleased to have you all with us
so yeah let's begin with today's session
as
we have reached the shadow time
so i would like to welcome you all first
of all for the very first session of
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
program
this program is dedicated to the study
of viral diversity and its role in
epidemic infectious diseases that keeps
re-emerging
including zoonotic spill over
transmission between humans and the
process of viral and bacterial disease
development
the participants will get a chance to
learn about bioinformatics and analyze
genomic data by applying various
analysis approaches to study viral
genomes as a result you all will learn
to understand the relationships between
viral strains and haplotypes
find differences in sequence data and
see the implications for drug and
vaccine design this program will provide
opportunities to practice analyzing data
to gain hands-on experience with curated
data sets from public domain collections
guided by experts with bioinformatics
experience and knowledge about virology
so before we begin today's session
i would first of all like
you all to go through some of the
resources that are going to help you
keep a track on each and every session
of the program
know about the session schedule and also
stay connected with our experts
so this is the program page where you
can find all the session details of the
program
the uh link is in the chat box thank you
jesse for sharing the link
now when you scroll down you can see the
session schedule where we have mentioned
the dates for each and every scheduled
session the topics that we'll be
covering for the sessions and also we
have some associated online resources
listed here along with each session that
you are supposed to go through now these
associated resources are the lessons on
the omixlogic learn portal that you're
supposed to go through and after this
particular session like today we have
the very first session where we'll be
covering the scale of sequencing
information available in genbank
metagenome viral sequencing data formats
for sequencing data we'll give an
overview of ngs talk about reads and
sequences we'll also discuss about
alignment annotation and non-map reads
we'll discuss about an alignment to
databases or viral genomes we'll explore
ncbi sra
and get a hands-on practical analysis on
t bioinfo server we'll visualize the
sequences on j browse and also
understand an example project that is on
sf9
now after the session is complete you
are going to get the recording of this
session
over here on the program page itself
just below the associated online
resources the recording would be
available you need to go through the
recording of the session and also
complete all the associated online
resources that i mentioned earlier that
are the lessons on the omnilogic learn
portal
and the same thing would be followed for
each and every session you need to also
click on the complete session button
that will get active once the session is
complete so you need to click on those
complete session buttons for each and
every lesson in order to complete the
program and get certified
the another thing that i wanted to
highlight was when you scroll down on
the program page you can see a list of
courses and example projects that you
have an access to as a part of this
program you're supposed to go through
these resources and also practice the
pipelines on the server and take your
questions from the experts now where do
you take your questions so when you go
through these resources practice
pipelines you are definitely going to
encounter some questions so to clarify
them if you scroll down you'll find the
link to the slack channel
i just refresh my page and show it to
you so this is the slack channel
now i have sent an invitation to all the
participants to join the slack channel
please try to join the channel and if in
case it doesn't work for you then please
let me know i'll send you an invitation
once again now on this channel we have
our mentors as well so you can just
simply post your query that you have in
the channel and the mentors will be able
to assist you
so that was about communication programs
schedule recordings and uh towards the
end of the session i'll be taking any
technical questions that you might have
so now it's time that we begin with
today's session and for that i'll just
pass on the stage to mr ilia protsky ceo
find biotech over to you
thank you so much
all right let me know if you can see my
screen
yes we can see your screen
all right perfect well welcome everyone
to today's recording
or today's
session there we go
um briefly i'll uh talk today in my part
about the program
and just to remind you you know what is
the goal of this program and what is
this program actually going to be
focused on so we're going to talk about
some of the tools methods and data
repositories we'll talk about some of
the curated examples and peer-reviewed
publications that you should try to go
through during this program
we'll
go through some tools so that you can
start analyzing data and you know where
to find the relevant resources
and importantly we'll talk about the
relationship between how data is
generated how it is processed how it's
analyzed how it's visualized and
presented to describe a specific
infectious disease or potentially how it
develops and what are the outcomes
we'll also talk about how as a part of
this program hopefully you will have the
opportunity to develop an independent
research project
and then present it to some mentors for
feedback
so
the program will talk about
tools that are commonly used and we'll
focus on that first so we'll talk about
things like sequence variation how to
align sequences how to
characterize the variation we'll talk
about evolutionary analysis and how to
link
mutation rates and time but we'll also
talk about the specific applications of
those in different domains and
importantly subsequence variation so
some consensus variation sorry
we'll talk about functionality and
protein structure how a lot of the
sequences that we'll be dealing with are
protein coding sequences and that's why
we can explore interaction between
different proteins and try to understand
what can we learn about the impact of a
particular variation on the the function
on how those interact
and then we'll also talk about
transcriptomic data analysis because
when we think about the infection uh the
viral or bacterial genome is what kind
of characterizes that infectious
pathogen but we're also interested in
the human response or host response and
we can characterize that really well
with transcriptomic data including
vulcan or a single cell or an asex so
we'll talk a little bit about that as
well
today though what are we going to try to
achieve today so first of all i will
kind of use this pandemic to talk about
bioinformatics and infectious diseases
and we'll talk a little bit about how
this pandemic really highlights the
application of bioinformatics tools
but we'll also talk about how it
guides the development in population
health how people are thinking about
epidemiology and also the development of
vaccines and antiviral drugs
and we'll talk about how this online
program
can work in the best way possible for
you based on your background based on
your interests based on your objectives
and goals where can you find the
necessary resources for you to be
successful and what can you expect to
get out of this program
so as solidico already mentioned
the central
uh location where you will find all of
the resources that you need is going to
be on this onyx logic portal
and what we'll do first is we'll make
sure that everybody is set up to do
everything that you need to do
throughout the program by completing
your sign up and your profile
so how many of you already have a
completed profile
all right anu
did you complete your profile already
okay let me show you
what a completed profile looks like
and then we will jump into our exercises
so here
if i log in to learn rxlogic.com you can
see that i'm logged in i can click on my
name
and that will be my profile
so you should be able to recognize me
hopefully look as beautiful as i do on
this profile picture
if you want to connect with me
you're welcome to
connect with me on twitter
on linkedin
i also see my orc id
right here and what i can do
is i can share with you my profile just
by clicking
right here on top and sharing my url
so as we're going to be going through
this program as a team as a group
let's make sure that we have all of
these profiles completed if something is
not complete you can just click on your
profile and right here you can add all
of that information make sure that you
include the full link to your account if
you want to share your social and if you
are not comfortable with uploading your
own picture uh you don't think it looks
that great you can just put a logo or
maybe some picture and that will help us
see that you've completed it actually
it's going to be important for you to be
able to work on an independent project
all right so i see that
um
clement has completed
and
i understand uh anu
also
did anyone else
all right
anaga thank you
if you have uh please share the link to
your profile
so we'll save that for later we'll be
able to follow up
all right briefly i'll show you what you
can do with this profile uh you'll be
able to go through different courses as
we go through the program
and these courses are going to be
related to different topics that we
cover for example infectious pathogens
like malaria evt 68 sars cove 2 all of
them have an associated publication with
a data set with some tutorial that you
can go through and that is a part of
this curriculum so as you go through
and you want to go back to where you
left off
sorry you can always see
that information right here
your objective throughout this program
is to get to 10 000 points so you can
see that i've been doing this for a
while i have over 26 000 points but all
you need to do is actually get to the 10
000 points and 10 000 points will allow
you to work on an independent project
so uh that project here i have some demo
examples but you'll be able to actually
start a new project and this is like
preparing for a publication so you'll be
able to use this as a poster
presentation we by the way have an
online virtual symposium at the end of
the summer that you're welcome to
participate in that but really how do
you demonstrate that you've learned
something in bioinformatics for
infectious diseases the answer is you do
it by showing showcasing your work and
showcasing your work also provides you
with the benefit of connecting with
mentors and experts in the field that
can comment and suggest improvements to
your project so this is a critical
component of this program and i'm really
hoping that you will be able to do this
now if you have a question throughout
this program
about the data sets about the right
kinds of research questions all of that
information we actually have a course on
that
uh and so one of the requirements for
anyone who would like to complete a
research project is number one
to have a completed profile
number two to get to at least ten
thousand points and number three is to
complete this course course nine
designing a bioinformatics research
project
so
why is this so important
this is important because
our objective throughout this program is
to help you learn about bioinformatics
and in application to infectious
diseases but also to acquire practical
skills
and one way that we can know that you
have acquired those practical skills is
of course to ask you
but if we just ask you and you tell us
there's really no depth to that
understanding so that's why we design
our process in the learning of omics
data and analytics
by structuring our content from
basic understanding the terminology
understanding examples understanding
what we're talking about all the way to
this independent thinking and ability to
construct an analytical process
by understanding what analysis matches
what kind of data
matching what kind of question
and all of those things are kind of
integrated on this online portal
so here's just some example of
recent graduates who have completed our
program you can see that
a couple of them have been able to cross
that 10 000 points but not everyone has
and that's okay because really the
objective here is to fit the program to
your needs and not the other way around
i hope that all of you would be able to
complete an independent project but if
you're not ready for that and you need
more time that's okay as well
but i do think that at least you should
be able to understand the terminology at
the end of this program
and showcase what you have learned and
that's why we have certificates
for each course that you will complete
we have examples so you can see how
these methods are applied in different
types of infectious disease studies or
experiments and you will be able
and sorry you'll be able to at least do
some literature review and kind of read
through the methods of these
publications and really understand what
others are doing
so before we go on i'll introduce myself
and another mentor that you will work
with throughout this program dr uh
raghav lakshmi narayan
uh my name is elia protonski uh
really i'm a manager but i do have
bioinformatics experience my background
is under applied mathematics and data
science and i'm currently doing my mba
but really i wanted to tell you about
the reason why
i'm interested in bioinformatics for
infectious diseases
and then if anyone would like to share a
little bit more about your background
and why you've joined this program and
what your goals are i'll uh kind of you
know
allocate some time for that
so uh right before the pandemic um i
was invited to participate in a project
that was
financed by darpa
and actually before the project that i
participated in there was another
project that we kind of applied for
grant funding to participate in and that
project was called prophecy
uh now prophecy sounds like you know
this uh interesting name uh practically
speaking what they were trying to do is
they were trying to develop
a combination of experimental techniques
and analytical and mathematical modeling
techniques to be able to predict which
viruses
might
break out might cause a an epidemic or a
pandemic
and how that pandemic is likely to
um kind of spread
so that original project i thought was
you know very fascinating idea uh we
applied for funding we kind of you know
thought about different types of tools
and methods and mathematical modeling
that can help us in that
ultimately we did not participate in
that original project but we reapplied
again in the next term
and that project was focused on a
therapeutic prevention of such an
outbreak so remember this is all before
the pandemic started no one is thinking
coronaviruses no one is thinking covet
but everybody in the group uh you know
these were people from stanford from
ucsf from nyu from all of these uh great
medical uh research centers and everyone
was
proposing their set of viruses so there
were people that dealt with ebola virus
and with nipah and with
all kinds of hiv and other types of
epidemic and pandemic type viruses
and
as i saw them interact it really drew me
into this whole topic because i realized
that
uh we kind of live in a world where
viruses bacteria pathogens
they um are out of the site until
something really terrible happens
and uh we don't you know all of these
people they were complaining about lack
of funding and lack of uh you know focus
and attention to what they were
developing and lack of kind of public
health policy about these infectious
diseases and and right
towards the end of that project is when
this pandemic actually started and and
that was just amazing to come into this
pandemic with so much understanding of
actually what's going on
what kinds of tools and methods and
ongoing research is going on and it
really allowed me to appreciate the work
that a lot of these research scientists
were doing at the time
and i even remember
after the pandemic kind of started to
subside i went back to the gym
and one of the people that we worked
with on this project became kind of a
more prominent public figure speaking
about the pandemic and the research that
they were doing uh at university of
pittsburgh uh and and i kind of knew the
guy you know and we worked together and
things like that so it was really an
interesting uh paradigm uh shift for me
going into that project and then
eventually kind of seeing how the
pandemic unfolded and is continuing to
unfold
so that's my personal story um of how i
got interested in bioinformatics for
infectious diseases specifically
uh is there anyone else that would like
to share kind of you know why did you
think to join this program now and what
would you like to achieve as a part of
your training
i'll just give it a moment if anybody
wants to
uh i'd love to hear
if not that is also fine
yes
go ahead uh
holocaust
my name is alcano i come from kenya
um
i've been following a couple of uh
our youtube
uh webinars from pine
[Music]
biotech
and i've seen the quality of the work
that they're representing
which is in line with
what i really want to
pursue in the future in terms of
applying bioinformatics and infectious
diseases
my background is in
chemistry
and i really want to
at some point get experience also in
looking at
the aspect of drug discovery in
for instance malaria
[Music]
yeah because in
in tropical countries like sub-saharan
africa
infectious disease is a public health
concern
yeah so i want to work at the interface
of
looking at
uh novell
drugs that are sourced from natural
products
and now understand that from
bioinformatics point of view
and i've seen that i might get that kind
of skills
uh set of i mean skill set
from uh buying uh
from this company
excellent
yeah thank you holcander and definitely
a very concerning and a big topic to
address there so thank you very much
hope that you know you achieve your
goals and we'll probably have a chance
to interact more about that
so let's give a chance to clement
clement uh would you like to share your
uh background and how
you'd like to use this time
yeah greetings from nigeria my name is
clement
i fell in love with bioinformatics after
attending a series of webinars
like my colleague from kenya just said
i
came across this training in one tele
telegram group
and
i appreciate the administrator for the
whatsapp group too
who decided to mentor me on this
after about 29 years of bench work
i just took up an
academic appointment and one of the
topics
listed by the faculty is bioinformatics
so i really look forward to
learning
the intricacies the applications
the foundation bioinformatics
thank you very much it's nice being with
you all
thanks
excellent excellent thank you clement
thank you very much
okay great so again we'll have more
opportunity to um connect with each
other and and get to uh know each other
so please
um you know continue to share your
links to your profile that's really i
think the easiest way for us to connect
in the beginning but let us switch gears
and we'll briefly talk about some of the
tools that we're going to be using in
this program and i want to give you a
little bit of an illustration today as
well
so you kind of get a sense of where
we're going uh what might be the
potential outcome towards the end what
you would acquire as a result of going
through this program
so we're going to be using uh these
three primary resources
uh one of them is going to be the onyx
logic portal and as i showed already and
solonica showed in the beginning we will
have project examples curated data sets
some training materials that everyone
will have the opportunity to go through
the second portal is going to be the t
bioinfo platform and has some dedicated
sections designed to facilitate the
types of studies that we will go through
and those include processing analysis
visualization of different types of
analytical methods like multiple
sequence alignment phylogeny
transcriptomic data analysis integration
machine learning and others and then we
will also learn a little bit about
coding in both r and python
now coding is like a language and you
know once you've started you can really
start speaking about anything that you
would like
but one of the important parts of uh you
know coding ex
exercises that we will do in this
program are going to be related to
the methods that we first cover on the
platform so you understand the logic
first why are we doing what we're doing
how do we get from a to b
and then we will look at typically some
packages that somebody already prepared
and we'll focus on the application so
we're not going to spend too much time
on the algorithmic part the mathematics
of these
methods but if you would like to you're
welcome we will share some publications
and some links where you can read more
about all of those methods
okay so again uh we don't have that much
time left but uh what first i want to do
in this first part of this presentation
is briefly talk about some of the
traditional and novel methods and
bioinformatics used for infectious
disease research and i want to give you
some examples that include working with
high throughput sequencing data
how to detect and characterize a viral
strain and also the relationship between
nucleotide and amino acid and the
mapping of sequence variation on protein
structures so these are some things that
we'll kind of go through
using this pandemic as an example and
then i will transfer over to dr
raghavendra and lakshmi narayan
who will pick it up from there and kind
of go in a little bit more technical
detail
and introduce you to some of the
resources that you can go into
as we progress with this program
so the coronavirus
this is a
an image from the beginning of the
pandemic
so right at the beginning uh people were
focused on the 2019 novel corona virus
and they focused on this epic center in
wuhan
where uh the comparison
was to previously existing viruses so
the middle east respiratory syndrome the
severe acute respiratory syndrome
and then they were looking at symptoms
and trying to understand
how is this novel virus different from
these other viruses that we already know
and we have studied because
coronaviruses have been studied
extensively for long periods of time
there are coronaviruses that infect
pigs and
cats and bats and all kinds of animals
they have had mild to severe outbreaks
like mers and sars but really they have
not spread that much and so what was new
and why was it important that we
understand the genomic composition of
this new virus
well the first thing that they did was
they did metagenomic sequencing
and metagenomic sequencing allows us to
take all of the genomic material in a
sample
and then try to understand what is the
actual full sequence of a particular
element so meta means a collection or a
combination of many different examples
and here we're trying to understand what
these examples actually tell us about
that one consensus genome that we can
call the assembled genome the full
genome of this particular virus
and when they did that they
then started looking at
uh how do we take this denovo assembled
gene know and start comparing it to
existing genomes so how does source 2 or
this novel coronavirus compare to the
existing coronavirus that we already
know and we understand and then we can
go into biological interpretation
thinking about how can it be different
how can it function differently how can
it cause an infection in a different way
so one of the critical things to
understand about this is that this
particular type of data that they were
using high throughput or next generation
sequencing data is actually a series of
very short reads ranging anywhere
between 150 and 300 base pairs in length
and they had to align into some other
reference
to understand the differences so what
kinds of differences could there be
so here we have the reference here we
have what's called coverage or all of
the reads that we have and then we can
start looking for variation so one type
of a variation is a substitution right
so we identify here
1213 that's the position on the genome
and we have five reads that all agree
that this is different from what we have
in the original sequence and that's
called a substitution
another type of a substitution as you
can see right here
is a substitution where we only have two
reads
right and they don't agree they don't
agree with the reference but they don't
also agree with each other
and finally another example that we have
here is an insertion which we can say
it's an insertion in the genome or a
deletion in the reads that we have
but ultimately this is a deletion
that we need to identify
as a
kind of something that we trust evidence
that we trust or something questionable
and so a few
conclusions arise from this brief
example one of the conclusions is that
the data can be more complex than it is
presented
the other one
is that
some of the regions are going to be more
trusted and others are going to be less
trusted
and we need to understand how the data
looks but also what the analysis was
that we used to be able to give this a
biological interpretation so because of
these elements we need to start looking
deeper at the data and not only trusting
whatever is being published but really
asking questions and we ask questions of
data using analytical methods
so let's take an example
from this pandemic and briefly go
through
how to do that
so very early on
there was a paper that was published
because everybody was concerned you know
where is this pandemic coming from was
it engineered on purpose you know what's
really going on and so a lot of people
were asking these questions and there
was a paper that was called the proximal
origins of source code 2
and i'll share the link here in the chat
where there were several arguments
presented
about the potential reasoning of how
people who
specialize in research in bioinformatics
for infectious diseases
think about
this data that emerged from this
outbreak
and so this is what they told us
they told us that
we have
the nucleotide sequence
we have the amino acid sequence
we understand what proteins are being
produced from this amino acid sequence
and therefore if we can identify the
relationship between multiple selected
strains of this virus that we have fully
sequenced
we can try to understand
why
this virus
occurred as a natural outbreak
and where could it potentially have come
from what was the potential intermediate
and the original source of this pandemic
so how did they do this
the first example that i want to tell
you show you is an example using the
t-balance for platform and this will be
a way for us to kind of explore the
platform but also continue talking about
this subject so the deep info platform
is something that
you have access to
through your account
and in on this platform we will look at
an alignment so how do we analyze and
align these sequences to the reference
genome
and what's called phylogenetic tree
construction so we're going to try and
do some of these examples um but just so
that you know you will have access to
this platform for the duration of this
program
and you will have five terabytes of
storage which will have a large number
of capabilities and you will have our
technical support to help you get
through some of these initial stages
so on the platform there are two
specific sections that we want to focus
on first
one is alignment to a reference right so
there we align reads to the reference
genome and we can identify specific
variants
or
alignment multiple sequence alignment
where we have multiple sequences that we
want to compare to each other and that
allows us to study relationships between
them by looking at a phylogenetic tree
the first pipeline organizes these these
methods right so each button here
represents a method
and as you can see those methods will be
con
constructed into a pipeline so a series
of methods organized sequentially one
after the other
given some input
make intermediate outputs and then
eventually produce a result what we call
a result and we'll see that could be the
alignment file or that could be a
phylogenetic tree so this pipeline will
look like this we'll take the faster
files of the spike protein
and then we will load them into this
pipeline
we will just use one button called
multiple sequence alignment
then we'll look at multiple sequence
visualization
and end
and as a result we will have this
interactive visualization that will
allow us to
navigate those sequences okay so we will
do this in the program we will not spend
too much time on this now to practically
go through this but then also after that
i will show you a pipeline that produces
a phylogenetic tree
so let me briefly show i'm sure that
most of you are already familiar with
these methods which is great but just as
a reminder refresher i will show you how
this might work
okay so first of all uh thank you just2
for sharing the link if everyone can go
to the server and let me know once
you're in
by putting in yes or
one
into
the chat box
if you're having trouble logging in
right now we can figure out what the
issue might be
so all of you should have the login
information if you don't we'll be able
to email that to you so let's just go
ahead and try that right now
okay so please let me know if you're
having trouble logging in other than
that if you are in and you can see what
i see and you can go right here and see
your email address
all right great thank you katie katie is
logged in anyone else
okay
so clement uh maybe you can try later
okay
and let us know okay ecta is not able to
uh
so maybe
hecta
could you please share the email address
that you are trying to log in with
so narika are you in here
yes india i have taken this email
address and i'll help you with that
perfect
all right great so
once you're logged in
for those of you that were able to
what you want to do is you want to go
right here into phylogenetic analysis
and i'll just show you briefly how this
works so you can either go into this
section and that will allow you to
upload files and actually do the
analysis
or you can click on this drop down and
you will see some demo pipelines
and so in the demo pipelines
you will see right here source code 2
origin
which is a pipeline that already has
been finished
and you can simply click on each button
see what the button does
and then prepare a very simple pipeline
so what we'll do is start multiple
sequence alignment
convert that multiple sequence alignment
to amino acids
this is a way to look at specific
positions in terms of mutation rate that
helps us make more precise estimates of
time based on mutation rate
then we will combine all kinds of
phylogeny methods together to prepare a
phylogenetic tree
we will analyze all of these
phylogenetic trees and select the
average one between multiple methods
which is a method in bioinformatics that
often is used when you have many
different things to do the same
step
and then we will run the pipeline
okay
so again start multiple sequences
alignment multiple sequence alignment a
a amino acid
select codon position msa all phylogeny
method tree space end let me know when
you have it
okay did anyone
did anyone complete a pipeline like this
if you have
then you should go to click pipeline
output files and find that you can
download here a variety of files from
this download folder
okay i'll just give it a minute
later on you'll be able to go back and
we'll actually show you where to
find this analysis in greater detail and
understand it but this is just to
introduce you to the tool today right so
this is just a way
to prepare a number of files that you
could either visually see like a pdf
download as a fast file or potentially
additional files like this full table
tsv
and the free file we'll talk about those
in future sessions
has anyone been able to run this demo
pipeline or is anyone struggling to find
where exactly i found it
okay
so um
again let's go into areas of analysis
how do you log in so i can log out real
quick
you see if i log out you click on the
login button right here
and you can use here your email address
with whatever password you have to
access the onyx logic portal
so if you have created your account
okay you gotta be logged in so let me
log in
so here i'm logged in
and now you click not on this not on
file genetic analysis but you click down
on this button
and you go to source code to origin
okay
so isha were you able to click there
oh yes sir up till now i can but when i
come to 5003 i wasn't able to click it
it wasn't showing
so you don't see this demo
uh so
all this i can see but when i come to
the pipeline in the last step i can't
click that one yeah
you can't click on this one
yeah
okay well let's try that together so
here i click on start
multiple sequence alignment
multiple multiple sequence alignment aaa
select codon position and then this
should be highlighted like this
okay
three space
okay
and
okay thank you
all right
all right excellent okay very simple
uh pipeline again take a look at these
output files we're not going to go
through them in detail the objective of
today's session is just to introduce you
to some of these tools
but if you have completed what we just
did then you know that you can always go
back
and you will find under all of these
different pipelines some examples that
you can go through and those examples
will be used throughout the different
sections that we will do right so take a
look at them
now one of the pipelines that i made
to kind of introduce some of the tools
has an additional button for
visualization right because just having
a faster file is not very useful and i
have this visualization and then this
visualization
i have a number of spike protein
sequences aligned to each other okay
so
why are we looking at these sequences
aligned to each other the reason we are
looking at them is because they can
reveal a very specific
pattern
that the authors of this paper in nature
in nature medicine
kind of linked used to
link this novel corona virus in humans
to a proximal origin to where potential
could have come from
how did they do it
so first of all
they selected very specific sequences
they said let's take human source code
to this new corona virus
and let's take the bat rad g13 a
genome that was sequenced very recently
before this novel coronavirus emerged a
pangolin stars cove 2 sequence and then
some previous
sequences of stars cov 1
from human and from back and so the
first thing that they found is that
the closest ones are human bat and
pangolin right
and here they noticed some very specific
similarities that were present in some
but not all
and since the pangolin bat and human
source of two overall were more closely
related to each other then they said
well in specific positions
pangolin actually resembles some
important features for its ability to
infect humans
more than the rad g13 bad genome right
and so that was their first conclusion
they said the receptor binding domain
we'll talk about that in a second is
much more closely resembled in the
pangolin sequence to the human rather
than the bad g third radicular t
and the second thing that they found was
that even though that they found
important similarities in the receptor
binding domain
in the poly basic cleavage site which is
another important section of that spike
protein
they found this unique sequence that was
only present in the human source code 2
which is p r r a
c sequence that was different from all
the rest
now to get to these conclusions quickly
we need to master some tools and these
tools oftentimes include some of the
simple things that we just did like
putting together buttons or sometimes we
need to go more in depth
and let's take a look at how you can
practice those things as a part of this
program as well
so
the first thing that i want to point you
to
is a lesson on the learn portal again
the objective
[Music]
of this session today
will be
to introduce you to where to find some
of these tools and exercises
so if you go to the courses if you're
completely new to bioinformatics and you
haven't really studied how to code
one popular language to do that would be
r
how many of you already are experienced
with r
i have some experience
is anyone here already
an expert in our
okay so
if you're not an expert yet i hope that
by the end of the program you will have
enough exercise
to be able to
feel comfortable with r at least
understanding the syntax
and really understanding how to use
you know the different libraries that
are used in bioinformatics so to give
you an example we're going to go to the
courses tab on the onyx logic portal and
right here let's search for genomics
so
what we're dealing here with are
sequences and these sequences commonly
come from
genomics they come from this field of
genomics that deals with analysis of
sequences
and
the first thing that we'll do is we'll
go to this lesson working with dna
sequences in r okay so
if you are
following along this is the link
and here
it gives a very detailed explanation of
pairwise sequence alignment multiple
sequence alignment etc and so this is
something that you can go through on
your own
but
you should be able to start
understanding as a result of this lesson
how can we deal with these strings of
letters in the case of dna it is t c g
and a
in the case of amino acids there's 16
different amino acids or 22
and we will also see how um we can
convert these sequences compare these
sequences align them and find
differences
so
the first lesson kind of introduces us
to a critical point in coding when we
use
languages like r
languages like r
use
objects and
they store information in variables and
once we have them they can use methods
designed to work with those specific
variables and objects to perform
different types of computations on them
so for example here we can load a string
in r we use this symbol
to equal uh to assign it to a particular
object
and then you can see that we can perform
different functions printing comparing
converting etc
so if you click here on next you will
see that there's some more exercises on
understanding the see the
the syntax
and once we go through the syntax
we get to a practice and the practice
will have a console
included here which you can actually
just run and if you run it you will get
a result
now the result here is about an
alignment score so here
you can see that we loaded some strings
and we compare them and we get a score
this is a similarity score for two of
these sequences
after we do that we can compare two
other sequences so notice here in the
beginning
the beginning is almost exactly the same
between the two sequences and our score
is 102.
in the second part we can run it and we
can notice that the score is actually
different so here the score is 55.
so it went down and we can notice that
in the beginning
they are not the same
now let's try over here to do an
assignment
in the assignment if we run it
it gives us an error
so now we can't just run it we need to
understand the syntax and we need to
apply what we have learned
to the assignment that we have
so right away what do i see because we
are paying attention to the syntax we
see that this function right here is not
finished pairwise is alignment should be
dnac1 dna62 right so we can just copy it
from here
paste it over here
and if i run it
what will happen
i will get a result
but
my result is the answer is incorrect
okay and this is an important point
because you will always get bugs when
you are running
some script and so now your goal is to
figure out well what is wrong
with this and the wrong thing is the
assignment of course it says let's use
alignment between the exact same
sequence how would we do that
well we could do that in two ways one is
we could copy the exact same thing
or another one because we have two
objects we can just compare the same
object to itself
right and if we do that
let's run on it again
and here again something is incorrect
okay and why because it says the one
stored in dna seek two so now let's
change it to dnasec2
[Music]
excellent now we have the correct answer
okay so this is how this works these are
exercises that are built to help you
think about
how to understand the logic behind the
analysis understand what goes into the
analysis and be able to practice it
until you get it right
so this was a little example with
pairwise sequence alignment in r
if you go over here you will find some
more practice for multiple sequence
alignment in r
and eventually you will also have an
assignment
that gives you a very practical example
about metabolism
of a
drug
where you have to write your whole code
independently okay so this is how these
work and i'll just show you the practice
example
right here
to understand
the actual visual representation of
those sequences okay and this is a
visual representation of multiple
sequences alignment
okay what do you do
when you have learned some of these
basics
like writing some code running a
pipeline now you need to get to
a way to interpret this information
right
so to interpret this in information a
lot of times
we have to deal with data visualization
data visualization can help us
look at very complex data and simplify
it to the point that we can start making
biological conclusions and that is the
essence of bioinformatics
so here i will briefly share with you
uh
this
uh colab notebook this is a notebook
that you should be able to run
in your
browser and
to run it what you should do is you
should go into the file
and
save a copy
in drive and so if you have a google
account you should be able to do that
it guides you through all of the steps
that you need to take to start
visualizing this data so to run each box
this is a jupyter notebook so to run
each box this is written in python you
would have to run this play button or
you can go to
run all right here
okay what does this notebook do and this
is kind of giving you the vision of
where we are going with all of this
information
here we will take some example files
from this study
we will then
load one of them and we'll identify
those specific elements like prra
right
we can find them
okay if you just search for them you
will find them right here
then
we will align sequences and we'll be
able to
navigate the sequences
for the full
uh
spike protein
okay and this is going to be
an interactive visualization
then after that we will load in
the spike protein
and we will actually look
at the receptor binding domain
looking at specific residues or amino
acids that are important for binding
and important for other things as well
and then we will construct a
phylogenetic tree first by looking at a
network
and that network will show us
some of those viral sequences in bats
and in humans like the rat g13 and the
human
and then finally we will create a real
phylogenetic tree
to understand how that could be linked
with time
okay
any questions this is just to give you
an overview of some of the tools that we
will go through
again we will go through
our platform the t by info platform to
see how pipelines are built
okay uh snare is asking a question after
opening collab where are you putting
this drive link so you go to file right
here
and save a copy and drive and that will
be your own notebook you can now save
this notebook and work with it in the
future
so did you find that sneha
all right
if anyone has any questions i will be
here to answer them but let me pass the
stage on to dr raghav to talk about some
of the details that i skipped to
introduce you to the tools and resources
of this program
so dr raghav over to you
thank you very much
let me find you guys to share my screen
so hello everybody uh
that was a detailed
talk uh presentation about different
tools
in
in the platform
so just like ella i mentioned what do
you do after learning all these tools
and after making
after gaining a lot of skills in
developing a lot of skills and
running your own bioinformatic analysis
and getting
biological interpretation
from the data that you have on the
output that you have
obtained so now what you can do is you
would be able to integrate you'll be
able to understand how different uh
research
papers are actually using bioinformatics
as methods and bioinformatics has a
different
field and
area of research to understand biology
in general so we will go over one
example pipeline one example project
that of various different example
projects that is available in the learn
on this logic platform and understand in
detail how this project is structured to
use bioinformatics to understand the
biology behind the system and the study
so the system under study is actually uh
sf9 or sporochtera to give through the
preda uh cell lines so to understand
what is specified or
what is for the vessel line so this is
derived from a mark that is native to
regions like um
usa to argentina and tropical regions
most likely so this is usually a regular
pests but it is most used in the
development and manufacture of different
biological projects as
available in cell in commercially
available sf9 cell line so this cell
line has been sequenced by various
groups for multiple different purposes
like agricultural biotech to protein
extrusion
usage so these
cell lines are actually established from
the tissue or ovarian tissue of the moth
and then they can be used for stable
protein expression and calcium protein
expression in a large scale protein
production bioreactors so we are going
to take a data from the sf9 cell lines
that are
made available in databases like ncbi
sra that happens and then we will try to
study uh the presence of contamination
in the
next generation sequencing data of sf9
cell line so why is this important and
why do we want to do this a paper
actually identifies unexpected sources
of contamination vital contamination in
sfl so to quote them they say that the
identification of that provider's
contamination in sf9 cells was
unexpected and as this cell line is used
in development manufacture of different
biological projects uh products
an extensive testing of
the different
testing for the presence of different
viral sequences as contamination is
absolutely uh required at this point so
in this project this is what we would
like to do we would like to download a
publicly available sf9 cell line next
generation sequencing data and then we
will develop a pipeline uh
for analyzing this cell line exchange
sequencing data for spiral contamination
so how do we do that
we download uh
the um
sf9 uh cell line sequencing data srv it
is available from a survey a database
and we can
download their
fastq files value output from the next
generation sequencing
machine and then we can
build a pipeline that resembles this
flowchart so what do we want to do we
want to first process the gene
expression data of the cell line and
then by processing the gene expression
data how do we want to do that we want
to take the first q files and then map
it on to the sf9 whole genome
and
after mapping the
reads onto the sf9 cell line genome and
then we want to look for those reads
which are left unmapped and when we take
these reads that are left and mapped we
want to
analyze these unmapped reads for the
presence of different viral genome or
the for the presence of different
contamination we can do this in multiple
ways one of the easiest way to do this
is to
directly take this unmapped genome and
then map it against the viral
contamination that we suspect that this
specific data might have
or the another way of doing this is to
take this uh
unmapped sequences and not reads and
then map it on to a database of viral uh
whole genome sequences to understand or
to identify presence of any other viral
contamination in the cell line data so
we will look to see how we can do that
so if and if at all if we find uh
contamination we can take these
take the reads and take the unmatched
trees and then try to find
their annotation or try to find which
part of the
contaminated
genome that these reads map to and try
to understand the similarity in terms of
mapping and in terms of
yeah in terms of statistics so
how do we build this pipeline so this
pipeline is
is a basic pipeline which takes a uh
reads of the sf9 it's a line
first few files and then maps it onto
the sf9 horizontal signal so this is a
very simple straightforward uh
transparency pipeline
that will take the first few files and
then it will uh map it on to the xf9
horizontal so many tools
and from this uh specific pipeline we
can actually navigate through the output
that is generated for this
pipeline and to those specific output
that
tells you or that shows you that gives
you where to find the reads that are not
mapped uh to the whole genome reference
statements that we have used here so we
we got hold of the leads that are not
mapped
to the sf9 genome and then as i
mentioned we can actually map it on to
the database of
viral sequences that is usually
found in ncbi virus database so how do
we do that we have an option of
selecting wireless genomes when we are
going to set up a meta genomics pipeline
so this meta genomics pipeline
like we can set it up like this
we take the
map we take the reads that are left and
back and then use power to align uh
functionality to
align it to the database of viral
horizon sequences so that we can get a
quantification or we can get an output
of how many different reads are mapped
onto uh different um
uh for example phylogeny or different uh
viral
zoom sequences so this is what we will
get as an example output so that this
table
is a count of reads for
each viral genome sequences so inside
the table it looks like
we have the
we have the access and id of the viral
genome mentioned here and we have the
number of reads that are mapped onto
this
so to get most significant mapping or
most significant
identification of viral
genomes contamination that is present in
these unmapped reads we can sort this
second column from
largest to smallest so when we do that
this is what we will get and we can
start looking for some extremely
significant ones and start annotating it
by
looking at these accession id and trying
to find what they are or or
which source they belong to so when we
find this source we can quickly
get a chart
like what we find here so some of the
important findings that we find is of
course um just like the paper mentioned
this
data also has this um
wrapped over wireless sequences uh
present in them so that we can also see
from here almost like one thousand eight
hundred trees or one thousand seven
hundred and fifty reads are mapped on to
these electro various uh sequences and
the significant significant
portion of reeds are also mapped out to
a similar virus for the as we call it so
ah this is also another discovery that
we
find little bit concerning because uh
previously this virus is linked
[Music]
linked with cancers or linked with
development of cancers from viral
vaccine contamination so it is very
important to address whether this
finding is
finding a significant amount or
whether this finding of stealth viral
sequences of simian origin
is very important as it can be
transmitted from human tissue so the
ability
in addition to this these viruses also
possess the ability to recombine with
another other human viruses that will
impact us and then this will lead to
some
genetic hybrid viruses with
increased infectious capacity so uh
that's that is another reason why um
scientists are studying for the presence
of uh estee party and other viral
ingredients in the
human genome with another other from
other possible sources of contamination
so let's
see whether if these numbers that we
find are of true concern how do we know
that uh it is of true concern so as i
mentioned we can take these unmapped
reads and instead of mapping out to a
database of vital
genome we can map it on to specific
virus whole genome sequences so in this
case as i mentioned let's start with
mapping on to
rhabdovirus and that providers that is
and then we uh
run the same pipeline but insert um
yeah here the reference sequence will be
random errors
so when we do that so what will we get
and we will get an output like this
where we can see the alignment
coverage for the whole genome sequence
or whole genome of the raptor battle
sequence so we see that most of our
reads cover almost half of the uh
genome sequence which is what uh
more or less the publication actually
reports
about the serious contamination of
fibroblasts in sf9 cell line data so by
comparing our results with the
publication results we can confirm that
this cell line next generation sequence
data also has the um
if not the same level uh similar level
of abdominal contamination to an extent
and we can identify that we can further
go on to characterize this in in terms
of what are the different
genes that are
present in this contamination and how
that might affect the
cell line uh
quality etcetera etcetera but we also
found something like simian
virus 40 in the
in the list so is that a concern because
in presence of semian virus
contamination a concern so we can again
start with building a similar uh
pipeline where we take the unmapped
reach and then this time instead of the
reference genome uh to be selected as
sf9 in the first case and rhabdovirus in
the second case we will choose the
reference sequence as semian virus 40 in
this case and when we do that we get a
visualization like this so in the whole
genome sequence uh of the simian virus
party
we get only a part of it is being mapped
to the space so it's very very small
part that has been mapped to the simian
virus 40 and since the
voltai to align uh algorithm that as i
mentioned that as i showed you
in here
counts only the number of reads and the
number of beads got mapped so high to
the simian virus
contamination but
the coverage is not uh sufficient for us
to create an alarm so this could be uh
and this could be only small portion of
the simian virus
similar virus genome that got we
combined two different sources and then
somehow we got its place in the sf9 cell
so this is not a concern but
the presence of rhabdoviral sequences is
a serious concern for sf9 cell lines
quality so uh
all of these information and in addition
to uh
finding the best annotation for the
rado virus sequences into which part of
the genomes get
maximally represented in these unmapped
reads are all described in great detail
in
this project sf9 cell biologics project
so i
i welcome all of you to join this
program and you'll gain many more
insights in trying to understand
different publications such as this
applications can uh that we have for
example projects that we have in line
out from sars from ebola from
mycobacterium tuberculosis and etcetera
etcetera so this will give you uh
idea about how biology bioinformatics is
generally used to
analyze big data with in in the context
of infectious diseases and also
understand the pathogenicity of the
source viruses or infectious diseases
and also
sometimes
the responses from the host upon this
pathogenic infection
so uh with that i open the podium
and passing that off back to
sonalika uh for yeah
for further classifications
thank you so much dr fargo for such a
wonderful session
and if you have any questions if you
have any questions please put them in
the chat box so that dr raghav can take
it up
or you can unmute yourself and then ask
your questions yourself if you have any
questions
yes definitely
all right so i'm assuming that there are
no questions uh so i quickly share my
screen now
yeah please you can take your question
hello everyone
yes
sorry uh
i joined you uh sorry so late but uh i
have
a question about is there uh is this cl
culture viral culture you talk about is
just like uh
mimicking a true one uh or
it is completely done on uh computer
no no it's it's maybe can the true one
it's actually isolated from the ovarian
cells of the moth
and then they are actually filtered for
uh
filtered and then processed and
through different
protocols for maximizing the so this is
used in
uh
large production of proteins and it is
used in other
selection of vector and etcetera
etcetera so this is
a very commercially available cell line
that is used for different yeah
in different
in different sections of the bioreactors
and
enzyme production and protein
replication etcetera etcetera so this is
very very popular seminar so you can
also look for this and that dimension
which is also commercial
so so so just to make it clear for me
this completely like a computerized
simulation right no or not no this is
not computer isolation this is full
biology so uh they have a proper
protocol of how to extract or how to
prepare the cell lines but that is going
to be that is probably patented by the
company which does that so all we can do
is to buy these cell lines from them
and use it for the commercial purposes
okay okay i mean
apart from the analysis of the data of
the next generation sequencing data that
is deposited for these cell lines in
publicly available repositories nothing
else is generated or nothing is
computer generated we are taking the
data digital data that is deposited in
the repository and then analyzing this
for the presence of a viral infection
as
uh identified and as pointed out by one
of the paper so that paper uses
different data and we use randomly
selected data and we also find even in
randomly selected data we find such
infection and this
such
contamination and this is a serious
contamination issue that needs to be
taken care of in accessing the quality
of cell lines for further biologics
that's why
good evening it's about around five
o'clock here in my
my country nigeria coming from nigeria
joining from nigeria
yeah it's
it gives us a lot of pleasure that it
gives us lot of purpose in
having participants like you
when you were waking up early and then
thank you very much
and thank you very much for everybody
joining from different parts of the
world at uh
v hours but not very usual
please
hello
i think
can you hear me
it's my connection okay
yes i can hear you uh
yes i can hear you okay
yes we can hear you
all right thank you um so as i was
saying if i'm
going to be corrected so the sequences
we're getting from to run this um this
um in silico
um experiments on um
bioinformatics i've gotten through um
from the lab right i got it yes exactly
probably people who are exactly exactly
exactly and a series of experiments have
been carried out let's say
from the pcr
to the
um several other experiments in the lab
right and then we get sequence and then
we run
to see the alignment with what we have
from the references from the query to
the subject of other viruses right
yes exactly okay
all right so i just i just wanted to be
sure because i'm currently
i'm doing um my in
the medical research center and this is
these are some of the things we do
and i feel very excited to be part of
this um meeting today as i spoke with
rashmi um i i begin to realize first
hand
the the
the implic and the application
of this
weight lab in conjunction with in
silicon or dry lab
so yeah so i just wanted to drop that to
declare if i'm following yeah thank you
so much
yeah yeah for sure there is i mean to
clarify your query and to clarify one
more uh from spanish
so um this contamination can be
uh it has to be actually verified by
locating that specific sequences and
then expressing them for the presence of
one ah one or two possible genes from
that specific or
but
the source of this contamination could
be from anywhere it could be from the
local lab or it could be from uh from
the place which
sequence the data so if the source can
be localized to one specific vendor or
one specific laboratory or one specific
sequencing
center
then
when we analyze completely a random
sequence that is deposited to the
repository by somebody else for the
presence of this
this viral contamination we should not
be able to find exactly the same
contamination that's the point if you uh
this
project or this actually this
publication actually gives way for the
possibility to do um
a method or this proposes a method where
we can scale up this identification of
contamination and then i
find or give us a surveillance of
how many
different types of contaminations are uh
have actually gone undetected in our
previous efforts that is what it
actually does so
by by combining or by comparing the
reads or by comparing the
shortly that are not mapped on to the
genome
to which it was intended to map on we
can take those waves and then try to
find to what other sources or resources
from
from different parts these genes or
these reads would have come from not g
these roots would have come from that is
what the aim of this
this
specific project on this specific paper
also uh yes halcan please
i think can you hear me
you can unmute yourself and
you can ask your query
yeah
thank you uh
the presenters who have given us this uh
wonderful
uh presentation full of
practical applications
my question is about
how long
can it take for for someone to publish
if you are purely dealing with
like a curated data set
i mean
how long does it take to publish like a
full paper depends on the data it
depends on the data it depends on the
question what what was required so it
depends on it depends on lot of various
other factors but what these methods
what our program actually gives you is
it it actually gives you a window to
understand how bioinformatics is
improving for different
in different analysis or in different
paper that either
performs or that either uses
bioinformatics as a main means of
analysis or main methods of analysis or
bioinformatics to supplement their
experimental finding or bioinformatics
to set up a big experimental story a big
experimental uh data experimental
experiment sorry yeah so uh these are
the three different aspects what you
will learn from going through this
program i mean to ask to to answer your
question there is a recently a paper
published from sars which i actually um
which i actually demonstrated in the
webinar of this
orientation webinar of this program so
this paper just simply takes the spike
protein and then calculates the
mutability index in terms of number for
each and every position of the spike
protein observes and then from this
mutations it also calculates the free
energy change for each and every
position for this type protein
of stars and then from this they
conclude which are the residues that are
susceptible to mutation based on the
free energy change and which are the
residue that are not susceptible to
mutation based on the free energy change
so by this they they actually can
predict whether or not a strain
that is recently identified or a variant
that is recently identified has a
potential risk factor
has a potential increase in dividends or
not so they this whole project could be
completed within three months
according to me but they published in uh
jack's journal of american chemical
society
associated i mean yeah
journal so that's that's it so you
that's the power of bioinformatics so
you can take a very uh i mean
very well curated data like sars that is
available for a long time and then it's
up to you to ask such a question
for which you can gain
impactful answers and then start writing
a publication so
that's what i wanted to say
okay do you also
you also like uh
uh have people like uh in groups so that
people can publish in group
uh yes i think uh i mean so monica can
comment more on this we encourage people
to team up to ask really big questions
so that some of them can ah can perform
one part of the analysis the other can
focus on the other part of the analysis
one can focus on the report writing
literature research etc we have a
research
fellowship program which i think
sonalika is going to give little detail
about
for what you can sign up and then
perform your own research on different
on various bioinformatics subjects uh
based on your choice or based on your
interest of what you want to learn so
that is something that you want to check
out from our uh
from our program list and there's
analytical please note that not economy
would want to gain more information on
this
and before passing this on to sonalika i
want to just mention
uh ahana or ahona if i'm pronouncing it
correct
uh i mean both
r and python have their own advantages
and both have a lot of
associated uh
resources
globally in the internet and also
anywhere else that you can look from for
bioinformatics analysis
at this moment
slightly the preference tends to be
little bit more towards r
uh because
because of the because of
because of the establishment that r has
got as a bioinformatics tool for that is
longer than python but python is also
catching up so if you want to start now
and start immediately analyzing in less
than one month uh i would i would
suggest you to go for our asset
uh not in python so
at least that is what my uh view
then i can yeah i can
pass this to sonalika
thank you so much dr raghav do we have
any more questions for dr raghav
if yes you can put in the chat
all right so uh i didn't buy
[Music]
i didn't invite uh
those participants who were also
interested to become a part of the
program but were not sure how the
sessions are going to work so for them i
would just like to go through the
registration process so that you can be
a part of the program and also join the
other sessions that we're going to have
this was also a demonstration for the
interested people so now you know how we
are going to have these sessions
conducted and work on the pipelines
so the very first thing is here is the
program page once again please make sure
that you go through these three lessons
and complete them and also complete the
assignment
and after the session is
processed that would be after few hours
i'm going to upload this
recording here on the program page you
can revisit the recording and click on
the complete session icon that would be
activated for you once the recording is
up there on the program page
the next thing that i wanted to take you
through
was the registration part so how do you
register yourself we have three
different uh subscription levels
beginner intermediate and advanced and
there are different
sorts of resources that you'll get an
access to uh with these three different
uh subscription levels being a part of
the beginner program will help you be a
part of such live sessions that we are
having right now and uh the resources
the access to the resources will remain
the same in all three of them uh they
just vary in terms of the duration and
also um
in types of meetings that you could have
with the mentor so intermediate level uh
like gives you an access to schedule
one-on-one meeting with the mentor and
in the advanced level you'll get some
extra time period to work on a research
proposal so you go through the training
process and then you finally
have a research hypothesis in hand that
you would like to work on
and it's very simple to pick any of the
subscription levels that you would like
to pick just click on the select option
button and proceed with your program
enrollment that was it about the
registration process
if you face any issues and
you are not able to proceed forward with
your
uh program enrollment you can reach out
to sparsh
at marketing at the rate omixologic.com
and she'll be able
to
uh get you enrolled the next thing that
i also wanted to put here was the
contact number for
the indian audience the number is nine
eight seven six one three four one two
zero you can reach out to sparshthar and
she will help you with any of your
questions
thank you once again for joining today's
session and uh those who have already
enrolled in the program please reach out
to me at support
address any technical issues and if
you're not able to join the slack
channel i'm going to send you the link
to our skype group so don't worry we can
also stay connected via skype
and please make sure
that you have updated your profile and
also you must have the badge of
infections in this program here in your
profile if you don't have it please let
me know also you must have the starter
subscription active for you that will
give you the access to all the start
lessons in the uh courses on the
omixlogic learn portal
so when you go to the courses tab and
you click on any of uh
the courses
you sh you'll find some of the lessons
are start so to get the access to the
start lessons you must have the starter
subscription active on your account so
please make sure that you have it active
if it's not active please let me know so
that's uh so that i can help you with it
uh carrie uh if you're getting an error
to join the slack late channel then i'm
going to send you the link to the skype
group as well
and uh yeah that would help you also
i'll uh try sending out the invitation
directly from slack if it works
otherwise we can definitely connect via
skype
yes thank you so much kadi